Hello Freak bitches.
I'm working on my second photo book.
My first one came out and uh,
the second one's going to be pretty cool cause it's all my North Korea shots.
That'll be crazy.
Oh Wow.
You went to North Korea to where?
We used to get that visa a few years ago.
So it was a sad when Kim Jong Il was still alive.
Uh,
it was a Kim Jong Il.
Yeah.
They'll let last days of Kim Jong Il before Kim Jong Moon.
And it was just a,
you know,
like when I was in new Iran,
just like they point you with what you're supposed to look at.
Don't look over here.
It's a propaganda to how much time did you spend a North Korea?
About a week I was in Pyongyang and the areas around Pyongyang and then I went
there via Beijing and then from there up to Mongolia,
then over to Butan what was North Korea life?
Just sad,
you know,
this poor people who are scared of their government.
And uh,
my tour guides since I went there alone,
they were very suspicious of me.
So sure.
You put two tour spies on me,
the Nice one who talked to me and the main one who just skeleton took notes and
every day the guy would ask me basically the same question.
It's like when a detective is trying to peel the layers of onion skin off.
So you said you're a businessman.
I'm like,
yeah,
I like it.
So what do you do?
Like,
you know,
I edit books,
which is true mine and it's a really,
what are the books about it?
I said,
well,
you know,
uh,
often they're not that good at winging it.
And so you're all putting one hotel,
uh,
you and the Dutch tourists and the Australians.
Everyone's in the one hotel across the bridge that's with men,
with rifles.
You're not going anywhere.
And so every day they go on their buses and I get in the car and the Australians
recognize me,
the Brits recognize me and they all want photos.
And you're walking to the,
um,
uh,
whatever that,
that room is the,
um,
the room where the north and south meet,
uh,
whether they come in through the northern door and the southern doors,
that blue room on the Dsj,
uh,
I'll,
I'll come up with a joint.
The JSA,
the joint security area,
something like that.
I pulled one of the Australians to the side.
I said,
can you please call your friends off me?
Because my tour spy is starting to ask me really weird questions about why
people want their photo with me.
And if I'm caught being in movies,
writing books,
rock and roll,
I'm going downtown for a meeting that I might not get out of.
And so he cooled out all his Australian friends.
But then there's this one British guy who just kept getting in my face with the
camera cause y'all are getting taken to the same places.
And I'll never forget this.
My tour guide,
who for the previous three days was like,
his English was from school like Ha Henry.
Uh,
he went from that to how does this guy know you?
And all of a sudden his English was as good as mine.
I'm like,
oh no,
and I'm not good at lying.
So I said,
I met him in the breakfast room.
I Dunno,
maybe he's hot for me.
I have no,
I just tried to explain it away and I just had to kind of go,
I don't know,
and I had to try and avoid this guy and I,
I was getting,
I was really nervous the last day I was there when they finally took me back to
the airport in Beijing.
I'm like,
damn man,
am I really getting on this plane?
And when the plane took off,
man,
I just like,
okay,
I did that,
but why wouldn't you just say,
I'm a musician.
I'm a good,
we will let you inform.
I went on a tourist visa and if you claim any of that,
you're going to get tons of scrutiny and they're not going to let you in.
They won't let you in if you're an artist.
Absolutely.
Absolutely not,
because they're just,
they fear it.
They fear what?
You'll go back to the mainland with something in the wrong because you're a
public person,
they don't want it.
But they absolutely let,
uh,
the basketball player,
what the fuck is he towed the party line and just told Obama,
you know,
just just call your pal Kim.
Sure.
That'll work out.
Great.
And same thing.
When I was in,
uh,
I was,
I went to Tehran via Dubai and the guy who met me at the airport after the
airport,
people got done grilling me.
Uh,
he said,
look,
I got your visa,
I know who you are.
I'm not your tour guide.
He's a government guy.
Don't tell him what you do for a living,
will never get you outta here.
So the last year is Christ.
Yeah.
The last time in that country,
I'm eating dinner with this guy and his amazing wife,
they're both like rocket scientists and the email they get by with a website
that gets thesis done.
So his cousin,
her cousin,
a new show,
the woman,
her cousin calls her and says,
your friend Henry's on TV.
And uh,
Achmed dropped his fork and said,
we've got to go.
We have to get you to your,
your hotel.
You got to pack up right now we just go to the airport,
check in,
check your luggage,
find a corner,
put your face in it and wait for the flight.
And I got to the,
I got to the airport like four hours early because you said you just,
you got to go.
Whoa.
And so I just sat there in the airport with my face down and then eventually got
on like,
you know,
the,
the 3:00 AM to Dubai and I was out of there.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
What would have happened if you get caught questions,
which leads to more questions and you just don't know.
It turns into like,
well,
he's been interrogated for the last three months and we don't know.
And since I'm not a hot looking girl,
uh,
President Clinton's not coming to rescue me.
And,
and so those are the two countries I've been to where don't tell them what you
do with what I was instructed before I left.
Wow.
Yeah.
Okay.